the bethesda.net launcher is closing the
playstation vr2 headset design has been
revealed and more
bethesda has announced it is closing its
pc storefront later this year in a blog
post the company thanked fans for their
support and assured them they won't lose
their games anyone who owns games
through the bethesda.net launcher can
migrate them along with any funds in
their wallet to steam beginning in april
most games will have their saves
automatically transferred too though
some will require manual transfers and
one title is not supported at all
bethesda said additionally the company
clarified that all bethesda.net accounts
will remain accessible all games will
remain playable through the bethesda.net
launcher until may but players have been
advised to begin the migration process
to steam in april when it becomes
available to do so regarding the game's
progression and save transfers bethesda
said in most cases this should be very
simple and it applies to most games but
not all for example wolfenstein young
blood progression and saves will not be
carrying over to steam
sony has shown off the final design for
its upcoming psvr2 headset and the
accompanying sense controllers which
feature a look similar to the ps5 design
aesthetic like the console the virtual
reality hardware has a white finish soft
curves and a matching orb motif
according to sony the circular orb shape
represents the 360 degree view that
players will feel when they enter the
world of virtual reality and ties into
the design aesthetic of the ps5 family
of products other features of the
headset include a focus on comfort as
the hardware has a lens adjustment dial
for users to dial in the distance
between their eyes and the lenses a
slight weight reduction when compared to
the previous psvr model and a new vent
design to prevent from fogging sony
hasn't revealed pricing or a release
date yet for psvr ii but the company did
mention that more details will be
revealed very soon
2k games has reportedly secured the
rights to adapt lego into a variety of
sports and racing titles the first of
these is apparently coming this year
with a very experienced developer in
charge according to vgc 2k games has
signed a new multi-game partnership with
lego that will see the company producing
a number of licensed titles the first of
which are a soccer game and an open
world racing game the soccer game
planned for release this year is
reportedly being developed by sumo
digital while the racing game is in the
works at 2k's own studio visual concepts
the games would not be the first lego
soccer or racing games but they would be
the first in a very long time aside from
a forza horizon 4 expansion lego hasn't
been adapted into a racing game in
decades and the same goes for soccer one
more sports game is also apparently
planned though it's unclear which sport
it will be
2k responded to vgc's inquiry with a
boilerplate we do not comment on
speculation response
sports and racing games are great but if
you can make a lego game based off of
any tv show or movie franchise which one
would it be let me know in the comments
and of course leave a like subscribe and
tune in tomorrow for another episode of
gamespot news
[Music]
you